oh my
here say you're all the way over there
where is the rest of your buddy the
absence of caribou has su chasing
ptarmigan around the tundra from me
she must harvest as many as possible in
order to fill her freezer before winter
returns I don't want to get too close I
don't want to scare with this wind
unless it's just a couple of feet in
front of me it's just gonna take shots
and pellets and fling them all over
sweet we had another one yes awesome
now got a couple go brush them out
their skin is very thin just pull on
them you want to sharpen up your hunting
skills because a lot of things are
hunting these guys right now if I can
see what they're eating I'm gonna know
where to look for him will Oh bud I got
the heart right there and his breast
this is about as fresh as you're gonna
get it nice little meal I better keep
going
there we go another term again that
first shot got him he didn't go all that
fuss why watch what he was doing when
over there I thought man no way I'm not
gonna have him suffer I'm gonna make
sure pop him one more good time and take
care of this business you know feathers
off this is meat but again I'm awfully
darn grateful for these little guys
thank you buddy
but what I don't use I simply bring over
there and there's gonna be foxes that
are out here all kinds of animals we'll
use that so again heart and breasts yum
yum yum
Colonel Sooners mmm
there's nothing like nice fresh meat so
thank you little birdies
you